hello everyone welcome to the biggest
ideas in the universe I'm your host Sean
Carroll and today we're doing the Q&A
session associated with video number
four which was space or at least idea
number four the videos have been
accumulating with the intro and the q
and A's and everything and so I realized
when we were talking about space when I
did the video for that I realized that I
didn't organize things in the ideal way
this happened sometimes right
casual informal this was as advertised
so what I did was I started with the
idea of dimensions of space
three-dimensional space why is it like
that could it have been different of
their dynamical mechanisms that could
change the number of dimensions and then
I went on to Hamiltonian mechanics the
position and momentum way of thinking
about things
yet another formulation of Newtonian
classical physics and then asking the
question why is position somehow special
compared to momentum trying to answer it
by saying because interactions in the
real world are local in position but not
in momentum so the second part the
Hamiltonian momentum part is more
important in some very real sense than
the first part for one thing it's true
like it's true that space is
three-dimensional but all the different
ideas that I talked about about why
space is three-dimensional are all
entirely speculative and they could all
be completely wrong it's important to
think about them it's important to
appreciate that these ideas are out
there and are contemplative all but I
wouldn't put too much credence in any of
them right now the state of the art is
just not that good and second this
difference between position and momentum
is a really deep fact that people don't
always appreciate and I think needs more
attention as we go forward into trying
to understand the fundamental nature of
reality trying to understand the
ultimate theory of everything quantum
gravity and so forth even just
understanding quantum mechanics this
relationship about why position is
singled out why we live in position
space not momentum space is something
that needs a lot more attention but by
putting it second and by putting all
this cool fancy speculative stuff first
people spend a lot more time and
attention on the number of dimensions of
space question that's fine you know but
I do want to sort of flip the switch
for the Q&A video because I want to
emphasize some things about Hamiltonians
and momentum because that's really you
know I think I think it is the more
important part of this particular
dialogue so let me talk a little bit
about oops let me talk a little bit
about phase space and hamiltonians well
what I want to do here really is nothing
that I didn't quickly mention in the
first video but I want to emphasize that
I want to go a little bit more detail so
it really sinks in remember that the
idea phase space was to plot something
like X and P now X is position despite
the fact that it begins with the letter
P P is momentum and I'm suppressing
dimensions here so if you live in a
three-dimensional space there's three
dimensions of X also three dimensions of
P there will always be the same number
of dimensions of X and P and then you
have at every point you have the initial
conditions for some physics problem you
have the state of the system at one time
if your Laplace is deamon the
information you need to know
besides the laws of physics is where are
you in phase space it's from that that
you can chug forward in time and figure
out what will happen next in the
Hamiltonian way of doing things what you
do is you define a function H which is a
function of X and P and it's basically
the total energy so it's basically the
kinetic energy plus potential energy of
the system and the wonderful thing is
from that from knowing what the
Hamiltonian is just one function you can
figure out all of the laws of motion of
the system what do I mean by that why is
that important or why do we care you
know in Newtonian mechanics we wrote F
equals MA and unlike before where I was
just trying to keep things simple and
approachable I'm drawing little vector
signs over the force and the
acceleration because they both live in
three-dimensional space there's an
acceleration and a force separately in
each direction of space so even though
this looks like just one equation there
are three separate components to this
equation okay it's a vector
not what we call a scalar equation which
we just have one component and there's
also the relationship P equals M times V
momentum is mass times velocity again
three components for those equations of
motion and the nice thing about the
Hamiltonian is that all these six
equations can be derived from this
single function the Hamiltonian that's
kind of an amazing thing that kind of
compactification if you like from many
equations into just one that kind of
unification is what physicists like to
see that's evidence that something cool
is going on so what I wanted to do is
sort of fill in some of the details I
already mentioned this before I want to
go and be a little bit more explicit
just to drive at home so what I said
last time was what you have is you know
your position and your momentum so what
you want to do is chug those forward in
time you want to know what are their
rates of change what are their
derivatives in time and then you could
just do calculus and figure out where
the system goes it's going to go on some
trajectory in phase space so you have X
you have P what you want are DX DT this
is the rate of change of position with
time which most of us would ordinarily
call the velocity V okay that's one
thing you want and the other thing you
want is the same thing but for
Momentum's you want D P DT the rate of
change of momentum and again in the
Newtonian way of thinking about things
we would say well position is mass times
velocity the rate of change of velocity
is acceleration mass isn't changing at
all we're gonna simplify our lives
thinking about it that way I once wrote
a whole paper with my colleague Greg
Anderson on particles whose mass changed
with time which you could get in some
cosmological scenarios
you had there like we do all Newtonian
mechanics because everyone always
assumes that the mass is constant but
anyway if P is ordinarily MV and the
derivative of velocity is acceleration
DP DT is MA which is just the force
right so in other words the equations
that we ordinarily get what I gave you
what it is told you is true in
Hamiltonian mechanics is that DX DT is P
over m that is what you get from
Hamiltonian mechanics and indeed looking
at both sides of this equation P over m
equals V is the same as P equals MV
which we think is true and likewise what
you get for the rate of change of
momentum is the force and indeed F
equals MA that's also true well I didn't
quite tell you at least I don't remember
telling you is how to actually get them
from the Hamiltonian I said I said it in
words but not in equations the answer is
what you do is you take the slope of the
Hamiltonian function in these two
different directions okay
in the X direction and the P direction
in calculus you know we talked about
taking the slope of a single curve
that's the origin of calculus the
beginning the first most obvious thing
you do the derivative okay so now we're
taking the derivative of a function of
more than one variable it's not just X
as a function of T that we're taking the
derivative of its H as a function of X
and P so what we do I'm gonna simplify
my life here by erasing this what we do
is what take what is called a partial
derivative which means we hold
everything constant except for one
direction we can move in and we examine
the slope in that direction so it's like
you're standing on a hillside you can
walk down the slope or you can walk up
it or you can walk perpendicular so the
slope is more or less zero right those
are all different amounts of slope
depending on what direction you go in
this is the mathematize ation of that so
the slope of the hamiltonian in the X
Direction is called the partial
derivative of H with respect to X funny
dhdx and the partial derivative in the P
direction is called funny D H DP
so these funny DS which mean partial
derivative
I think we're invented by Laplace no no
applause live knits the competitor to
Newton to invent calculus they're
they're sort of related to the Delta
which is the actual Greek letter these
funny DS that are written like this are
called Dells and they're only used ever
in calculus they're not letters in
anybody's alphabet they're just special
calculus symbols and what they mean is
hold everything constant move only in
one direction hold everything except one
direction constant move in that
direction calculate the slope this is
known as the partial derivative okay and
that's where we get these equations for
the change of X and the change of P DX
DT in Newtonian in Hamiltonian mechanics
turns out to be the partial derivative
of the Hamiltonian with respect to
position with effective momentum so are
these vector momentum so dxdt equals D H
DP that's good what if I said what is
the rate of change of momentum well
you're probably going to guess given
that there's some kind of symmetry
between X and P that it's the partial
derivative of H with respect to X with
respect to position you are almost be
correct
it's minus that okay why is it minus
that you know there's a deep Matt the
answer that involves the symplectic
structure on the manifold that we call
phase space none of which we're gonna
get to or at least unless this series of
videos goes on for about 130 videos
we're probably not going to get to the
symplectic structure on phase space here
but what we have well you'll just trust
me is true is this equation relating
momentum to the Hamiltonian and the
derivatives of the Hamiltonian so
there's us some kind of symmetries a
little bit more complicated than just
replacing X with P but the point is from
this one function H you can just take
its slope and figure out how fast
position will change how fast momentum
will change and that's all you need to
move forward in time to integrate to get
the solution that's how Hamiltonian
mechanics work
and what I really want to do here is dig
a little bit deeper than that by doing
an example you know like the spirit of
these videos is not doing worked
examples very much including all the
math but you know sometimes that's kind
of healthy thing to do
so let's actually do it let's do an
example of a Hamiltonian and how to get
the equations of motion from it so
what's the simplest example we can do
the example would mean by an example
well we have some function of X and P
which is supposed to be the energy
kinetic energy plus the potential energy
we're going to pick the simplest
function that we can pick right well
what is the kinetic energy it's one-half
MV squared and we said already that if
you already plug in P equals mV that is
1 over 2m P squared that's the kinetic
energy plug in P equals MV you could
check that and then the potential energy
you said is just gonna be some function
of X but we don't want to be that
abstract or that general we want to do a
specific example so you want to actually
pick some function let's just pick a
nice symmetric looking function about
1/2 K x squared ok so just like there's
a P squared there's an x squared and
this looks very kind of even-steven in
terms of what the position is doing and
what the momentum is doing in this
example in fact this example is super
famous this is the simple harmonic
oscillator why is it famous two reasons
one because it's simple enough that you
can solve all the equations exactly the
other is things that are approximately
simple harmonic oscillators appear all
the time in the real world so let's
imagine you have a wall here surface and
then there's a box on the surface and
it's frictionless surface and there's a
spring connecting the holding box to the
wall so there's some position at which
we'll call x equals 0 where it's an
equilibrium the springs neither pushing
it or pulling it K can be thought of as
the strength of the spring the spring
constant and then when you move the box
in one direction or another the spring
will either push it
back or pull it back to where it came
from and if you push this back and forth
this gives it has a potential energy V
of X is in fact 1/2 K x squared so it
looks like this it looks like a parabola
as a function of X this is the simple
harmonic oscillator that is its
Hamiltonian so when you have questions
like why is the Hamiltonian that why is
it that function of X and P the answer
sadly is well that's the Hamiltonian
that works to describe the physical
behavior of this system right what
you're really asking is why is the world
like that and so sometimes that's the
kind of question that has an answer
sometimes it's not right now we're just
gonna say the world is like that for
this particular little world with a
simple harmonic oscillator in it okay
and we what we want to do is we want to
actually find how these equations the
rate of change of position is the
partial of H with respect to P where
change momentum is minus the partial of
H with respect to X so how they work for
this particular system the simple
harmonic oscillator okay we're actually
gonna do the math and so one little clue
I'll give you one clue one math clue you
know we're not about solving equations
here in these videos but we want to do
it now if you have a function y equals x
squared and you want to take the
derivative I'm going to take the slope
the answer is dy/dx equals two times x
more generally if you have X to some
power when you take its derivative you
bring that power down in front and you
lower that power by subtracting 1 so 2
minus 1 is 1 X to the 1 is just X so the
derivative y respect to X is 2x squared
so what do you want to do we want to get
DX DT we want to set that equal to the
partial derivative of the Hamiltonian
with respect to P so this means keep X
constant if I look at the Hamiltonian if
I keep X constant I just fix the
one-half KX squared that doesn't do
anything at all all it affects anything
is the P part and I differentiate P in
fact a differentiate piece
so what I get is one over 2m times
derivative P squared which is 2p and
guess what that is just P over m that
looks familiar doesn't it because that's
what we said was the rate of change of
position is P over m but we didn't
assert it here we derived it we derived
it from this very simple form of the
Hamiltonian likewise if we said what is
DP DT how quickly is the momentum
changing over time that's minus the
partial derivative of H with respect to
X so that is - where's H over here here
it is minus 1/2 K and then the
derivative of x squared is 2x so it is
minus K X what that means is exactly
what our picture is showing here if we
had this box displaced a little bit okay
so that X is some positive number here's
now x equals 1 let's say okay well this
is saying that the force that is acting
on our box is minus that displacement so
the force is pulling the box back just
like it should be doing so this is nice
I mean I know it's math what some of you
love math and this is all trivial and
kind of boring some of you hate math and
this is scary and intimidating no matter
what the point is we can use these
mathematical techniques to start from an
extremely simple expression right here
and derive all the equations of motion
in a very very simple way in fact let me
mention that what I said in in the
previous videos was there's something
called the Newtonian way of doing things
it's a little bit confusing because
sometimes the phrase Newtonian mechanics
just means classical mechanics sometimes
it means Newton's actual way of doing
classical mechanics F equals MA right
now I'm using it in the latter sense and
we argued or I said that Newtonian
mechanics is equivalent to
something called the principle of least
action it's a different way of thinking
about classical mechanics and I also
said that it's equivalent to this
Hamiltonian way and this is in fact the
demonstration what I just did with the
math is a demonstration that you could
derive Newtonian mechanics from the
Hamiltonian it turns out also to be true
that he could skip the Newtonian step
and relate to the action to the
Hamiltonian directly that's another way
of doing it
in fact Hamilton who came up with the
Hamiltonian also came up with sort of
the modern version of the principle of
least action which is sometimes called
Hamilton's principle but there's there's
details and people argue about the
nomenclature etc anyway all of this is
to say this way of doing physics is very
powerful certainly when you look at
equations like this for the Hamiltonian
PNX look very very symmetric there right
but when you look at more complicated
systems when you look at systems that
are doing something other than being a
simple harmonic oscillator you typically
add more terms with X's in them you
change the dependence on X you change
the potential energy but you don't
change the 1 over 2m times P squared the
kinetic energy just is the kinetic
energy usually there's always exceptions
so that's where the asymmetry comes in
at this level momentum and position look
exactly the same it's only when you
complicate the world and have many
moving parts and many different
potentials and many different forces
that position and momentum start looking
very very different ok that was all to
make myself feel better because I wanted
to give you more details about
Hamiltonian mechanics let me actually
answer some of the questions that were
addressed after the video came out so
questions one very simple one was about
entangled particles I'm gonna write the
question let's go say it in words
because it takes too long so I wrote
about entangled particles and I said I
forgot which notation I used but if you
have spin up and spin down I said look
they could both be spin up or they could
both be spin down or there could be some
combination of both and a lot of people
wrote in more than one person and said
wait a minute
I thought that when particles are
entangled
spins are always opposite so it's one is
up one is down or one is down one is up
the answer is these are two different
possibilities that are both real
possibilities the fact of entanglement
has nothing to do with whether the spins
are in the same direction or the
opposite direction it's just about the
fact that they are related to each other
in some way so if your state was just
this the spins are up both spins are up
okay that's not entangled at all the one
spin is up and that's completely
independent of the fact that the other
spin is also up right there just true to
true facts these are entangled because
once you measure one spin you have
learned something about the other spin
whereas this is not entangled in fact
let me write another one here is one
spin is up and the other spin is in a
superposition of spin up and spin down
so I wrote that badly sorry the whole
point here is this is not entangled and
this is not entangled either you don't
learn about one spin by measuring the
other one so you could have all sorts of
different things it is true that this
particular state where the spins are in
opposite directions is a very popular
one it appears a lot in a lot of real
physical situations it's often the
lowest energy state for these two spins
to be in but it's not the only state we
can be in all sorts of things that was
one question here's another question how
can a dimension be small so the reason
why this is a question you know I said
dimensions can be small but I also said
that dimensions are not places to go
like sometimes you know you watch Doctor
Strange and you you know you see that
there's a dark dimension with all the
demons in it and you think of a
dimension as a location out there in the
universe and I try to emphasize that in
physics a dimension is just a direction
in which to go so people some people
thought that there there seems to be
some tension between that and they said
you know how can a direction
be small right I mean a direction exists
at every point there's all the different
directions you can go in so that's a
very good question because it's I'm
you're you've caught me this is using
terminology in the slapdash ways that
physicists often use it the example you
know I gave was something like a
cylinder very long skinny cylinder okay
so here you have X in this direction and
maybe Y is the direction that wraps
around at any one point on the cylinder
there are absolutely two directions you
can move it right x and y this is two
let's see it's not like X is better than
Y or anything like that but at the same
time if you go in the Y direction
there's only so far you can go before
you come back to where you left so we
use the word dimension sometimes when we
say small dimension we don't mean
there's a direction you can move in that
is small we mean there's a direction you
can move in such that if you move in
that direction
you can only go so far okay that's what
the phrase a small dimension of
space-time means and the reason why
that's an interesting thing is because
if you imagine making that dimension
smaller and smaller right you imagine
making that circle shrinking down to
smaller and smaller sizes it becomes
indistinguishable from that dimension
not being there at all so when you can
only observe things at large distances
the existence of a dimension of space
that is much smaller than you can
observe might as well not be there at
all so there's a relationship in quantum
mechanics and this is getting us too far
afield but maybe in future videos this
will be become clear small distances
correspond to high energies and large
masses of particles so big particle
accelerators that can reach high
energies are like microscopes that are
looking at smaller and smaller distances
but there is a limit right any one
accelerator only goes up to a certain
energy so above the energies that
particle accelerators have ever probed
if there is a dimension of space smaller
than the distance corresponding to those
energies they will be invisible to
that is if the dimensions are at the
Planck scale which is something like 10
to the minus 15 times the smallest
distance we've ever probed we would not
be able to see them at all roughly
speaking that's what it means for a
dimension or direction to be small okay
another good question was string theory
which we mentioned as a potential theory
of gravity and other forces of nature
how many dimensions and this is another
great question perfectly a great
question in the sense that is a
perfectly valid question you're
perfectly right to be confused depending
on what you've heard about string theory
before you might have heard that string
theory has 26 dimensions you might have
of space-time dimension the space-time
in this case not just of space you might
have heard that it has ten in way to
further that it has eleven okay why do
you have all these different numbers so
the answer is they're just different
versions of string theory or if you like
there are different theories that can
descend from string theory in some
particular situation so the 26
dimensional number comes from what we
call boson ik string theory you might
have heard that in nature when we have
fields or particles they come in two
basic varieties bosons and fermions
bosons can pile up on top of each other
so like Higgs bosons photons and
gravitons or bosons W and Z bosons
fermions take up space so like electrons
neutrinos quarks etc or fermions it's
easier for various technical reasons for
field theorists to work with bosons than
with fermions so when string theorists
first wrote down string theory they
didn't put fermions in and what they
found was their theory of boson ik
strings only works in 26 dimensional
space-time okay
my only works what I mean is there's
some symmetries that are really really
crucial to the internal consistency of
string theory and when you quantize the
theory it turns out that those
symmetries get broken unless you're in
the right numbers of dimensions so this
is called the critical dimension of
string theory
the the number of dimensions oops
just dimension singular the number of
dimensions in which string theory works
quantum mechanically the symmetries are
not broken but then when you add
fermions it turns out that though again
the weight that works the way that is
consistent with all the symmetries etc
you add an equal amounts of fermions and
bosons and you get supersymmetry and
this is where you get super strings
super strings naturally live in ten
dimensions that's the number of
dimensions of space-time in which super
strings can propagate and interact with
each other
consistently coherently not breaking any
symmetries the eleven dimensions is kind
of a sneaky thing so before there was
super string theory there was super
gravity super gravity is not a string
theory it is a version of general
relativity of Einstein's theory of
gravity that has been made super
symmetric okay so there's no strings
involved it's field theory but it's
super symmetric field theory
supersymmetry I should say I really
should tell you what that means
supersymmetry is a symmetry between
bosons and fermions it is not a symmetry
that exists in experiments as far as we
have yet been able to tell but it might
be hiding from us it might be there we
just haven't yet observed it it's very
very popular among many theoretical
physicists so super gravity is a version
of gravity that is super symmetric for
the same kinds of reasons as we talked
about super gravity naturally lives in
11 dimensions and this is fun actually
there's a fun thing to talk about here
because it's a little bit of interesting
history of physics in the 1980s 1990s
there were already people working on
super gravity but it super gravity
doesn't have all of the nice features
that string theory has it's there are
certain features of string theory that
were hard to prove would also hold just
in super gravity so there was a plucky
minority of people who worked on super
gravity just out of stubbornness and
they liked it they they weren't really
looked upon very highly by the super
string
people but then it turns out that super
gravity which naturally lives in 11
dimensions contains even though it
doesn't contain the strings
two-dimensional brains so remember I
think I mentioned something like this
this is a brain a brain is a
two-dimensional sheet instead of a
one-dimensional string if you like a
string is a one brain a two-dimensional
sheet is a two brain a three-dimensional
jelly is a three brain there are eight
dimensional brains and the whole bit you
can imagine anything like this that's a
it's a back construction from the word
membrane because back you know hundreds
of years ago no one invented a word for
an eight dimensional object who knows
why so it very very naturally
supergravity contains these
two-dimensional brains but they weren't
fundamental they were just you know they
seem to be features of the theory but it
was hard to know what status they had it
so forth then the 1990s joke polchinski
especially but a bunch of other people
realized that string theory also
contains a bunch of higher dimensional
objects a brain like objects of all
sorts of different numbers of dimensions
so the idea that string was strengths
areas not just a theory of strings
became very popular and then the idea of
super gravity with its two brains was
sort of reexamined and it was ed Witten
who actually figured out ed Witten you
know the most famous string theorist
alive he realized the following thing
imagine you have a two-dimensional brain
but you also have one compact dimension
of space okay so this is let's say you
have eleven dimensions of space-time
that's ten dimensions of space let's
imagine you have nine dimensions of
space that are big and then you have one
dimension of space this one that is
small
so this is where this is a particular
configuration in which super gravity
could live right and then you can take a
brain and you can wrap it around
so in fact I realize that this is not
the best drawing to make let me unwrap
this because I need to draw more than
one big dimension I drew one big you
mention this way and he'd draw two of
them so what I want to draw is something
like this so what this is supposed to
mean is imagine you're identifying the
top and bottom here so this is actually
a circle and these are two big
dimensions and that's the one small
dimension so this is three dimensions
that I've drawn here right two big one
small
I'm suppressing the rest of the
dimensions but imagine this is part of
an 11 dimensional space-time okay you
get that so if I if I zoomed in here
what this means is if I'm in this
surface if I walk upward and I get to
the top I suddenly boom appear back in
the bottom it's just like a one
dimensional torus which we call a circle
okay so this is two big dimensions in
one circle and imagine this is part of
super gravity so I've suppressed the
other what is it if I have nine
dimensions of space total No ten
dimensions of space total nine of them
are big one of them is small good that's
what I drew but now I have
two-dimensional brains living in this so
there's two possibilities one is the
two-dimensional brains can sort of
stretch across the big dimensions but
there's another possibility that they
could just like be embedded in the small
dimensions so imagine the
two-dimensional brain did something like
this right so what this is saying is
there's two dimensions but one of them
is wrapped around the small dimension of
space and the other one dimension is
stretched into the big dimensions of
space then to the point of view of
someone who only lives in the big
dimensions some low-energy observer that
two-dimensional brain looks
one-dimensional that is to say it looks
like a string
so what women realized was you could
start with 11-dimensional supergravity
compactify it along one dimension and
the two-dimensional brains of
supergravity would become
one-dimensional strings so he realized
there's a relationship between string
theory and super gravity and the
relationship is they're both two
different aspects of the same underlying
theory which he named M theory
that's what M theory is it's the unknown
we still understand it 'mother theory
magical mystery theory behind it all and
the 10 dimensional superstring theories
there are five of them if you want to
count are all different limits different
approximations and different
circumstances of M theory and 11
dimensional super gravity is another
limit another approximation of M theory
so that's the relationship between the
11 dimensions and the 10 dimensions the
26 dimensions just a you know is a good
first try okay the 10 10 dimensions and
11 dimensions are real honest but
different limits of the underlying M
theory was probably more than you wanted
to know or more than I wanted to say but
this stuff is so cool I just can't
resist okay continuing on are there
alternatives to compactification what I
mean by this is
I said are there I said there are ways
to hide but extra dimension by making it
small are there ways that we couldn't
see an extra dimension even if it
weren't small even if it were big well
the answer is yes otherwise I wouldn't
be talking about this and the answer
comes exactly from this idea of brains
so imagine that you are here's some big
dimensions okay and let's three big
dimensions of space and let's wrap
around these three big dimensions of
space let's wrap around a brain okay a
two-dimensional brain just to make our
lives easy so this is a brain and this
is space that's easy enough to do but
the important thing is people realized
very early on in the theory of d-branes
that from boat in ski and others but
there could be particles and fields
stuck to the brains okay that it's
there's every by the way every joke
relating B or a and E to be our AI n has
been made they've been Papers written
about brain surgery and all that stuff
okay so forgive me for that I'm not try
to make them here anyway you can imagine
people people made of particles who
essentially are only living on the
brains right cannot get out into what is
called the bulk the bulk is the rest of
the universe so you might think that we
don't have to compactify at all what if
there's a three-dimensional brain
embedded in nine dimensional space of
one of those superstring theories or ten
dimensional space of super gravity well
it doesn't quite work because there is
one force of nature that cannot be
confined to the brain not at least in
ordinary circumstances which is gravity
gravity always reaches out into the bulk
because gravity is a feature of
space-time itself it's not something you
can confine to a brain so there are ways
that the extra dimension could be bigger
than you think but you have to sort of
fool around a little bit one way is that
we live on a brain and the extra
dimensions are bigger than you know an
atom but small enough that we don't
notice
gravity leaking out experimentally these
days that's about 1/10 of a millimeter
so if the whole size of the extra
dimension is smaller than 1/10 of a
millimeter and we are stuck on a brain
inside that extra dimension that is
compatible with experiments as we know
it today the other way to do it is if
the geometry of space in the bulk is so
highly warped that effectively gravity
doesn't get out there at all if you
change the geometry of space from being
flat to being bent then it's harder and
harder it can be harder and harder for
gravity to get out this was a theory
invented by Lisa Randall and Raman
Sundaram warped compactification x'
and Lisa wrote a whole book about it
warped passages again no evidence
experimentally that any of this is true
there's upper limits on how much it
could be true but the point is you can
imagine different scenarios and you know
in the 1990s this was full employment
for theoretical physicists to imagine
different ways you could try to hide the
extra dimensions these all were
wonderful real theories that made
predictions and we want to look for the
predictions that we haven't seen any of
their predictions come true yet it might
happen tomorrow it might happen in
between when I record this and when the
video appears but right now it hasn't
happened yet so again all this talk
about extra dimensions so far is
entirely hypothetical ok getting a
little bit more deep if you want it is
already pretty deep right but there
there was a question about locality and
holography which I'm gonna not say a lot
about because we don't quite yet have
the tools on our plate to think about
the holographic principle but I respect
this question because it's really
completely on point when it comes to
locality the point is there are things
called black holes here's a black hole
and you know black hole will get into it
but a black hole has the feature that if
you're a person outside if you fall in
you can't come back out it's a one-way
street ok but Stephen Hawking showed
there are particles that will be
released Hawking radiation and what that
means is that eventually the black hole
will evaporate away will lose all of its
mass and it will disappear and there's
something called the black hole
information loss puzzle relating the
amount of information quantum
mechanically that you could put into the
black hole and get it out by the Hawking
radiation the reason why I'm mentioning
this is because we're not
I'm not going to nearly enough details
to understand it but the insistence that
the information that goes in must also
eventually come out is just Laplace's
daemon doing the insistent
insisting right it's the quantum
mechanical version of Laplace's daemon
it's physicists being absolutely
convinced that there is a conservation
of information over time that the
information that exists in the universe
at any one moment of time is the same at
any other moment that's what convinces
them the information must eventually
come out of the black hole but there's a
lot of you know thought experiments
associated with this and the whole thing
and what people eventually realized
Hawking radiation also implies that
there's entropy that the black hole has
but the entropy turns out to be
proportional to the area of the black
hole's event horizon a black hole as a
sphere or a spherical topology anyway
and it has an area for these event
horizon and you can calculate the
entropy and what that seems to imply is
that the amount of information contained
in a black hole is distributed on the
surface area of the black hole
now I'm there's no reason you should
believe me when I say that I haven't
filled in the details there's a
relationship between information and
entropy and it's a relationship in the
case of black holes between entropy and
area whereas if you just had space if
you have space and locality if you
really believe in locality as I've been
pushing here locality might make you
think well locality would make you think
that at every location in space there's
a bit of information or these some bits
of information some amount of
information
and that information is separate from
the information that is at some
different location in other words the
amount of information should scale as
the volume of space there are subtleties
here because of quantum mechanics and
entanglement and so forth but the number
of particles that I could put in the box
should be proportional to the volume of
the box over here with a black hole it
seems to be proportional to the area
which is a different number so Gerard a
tuft Nobel prize-winning physicist then
leonard susskind another famous
physicist who appeared as a guest on the
wine scape podcast proposed this idea of
the holographic principle that this
relationship between entropy and area
was real it was physical it was it was
meaningful that there was a real sense
which we can think of black holes
literally as being defined by
information living on their surface area
so that seems to be at odds with the
idea of locality and all I'm gonna say
here is yes it is yes it is and this was
this cause has cause continues to cause
great consternation there's another
version of holography called the ATS CFT
correspondence invented by juan malta
sane and where things are much more
specific and it's perfectly clear that
locality is violated in some sense
that's a situation where you have one
theory one theory of physics okay one
Hamiltonian if you want which can be
thought of as two different space times
two different field theories living on
two different universes and those space
times have different numbers of
dimensions so there's no one-to-one map
between locations in one's face time and
locations in another so locality has to
be violated some way and the upshot of
this for just answering this question is
when gravity becomes important all these
are gravity right a DSC of T black holes
the holographic principle this only
comes in when gravity becomes important
when you have non-gravitational quantum
field theory this idea of locality and
all the different locations in space
being separately defined makes perfect
sense the number of things that can
happen scales with the volume not with
the area
gravity changes things and there's
actually other reasons to think that
once you have quantum gravity locality
can't be sacrosanct anyway so rather
than saying locality is absolutely the
most important thing how can we
reconcile these weird features of it I
think that we should bite the bullet and
say look once gravity is in the game
locality is just an approximation
locality manifests itself it emerges
it's an emergent phenomenon in certain
situations where gravity is not that
strong and where gravity is strong like
in a black hole or in these anti-de
sitter spacetime ABS universes locality
is not going to be exactly right it's
still approximately right in the same in
the same set of limiting circumstances
so that's the thing we need to
understand not how to save locality
perfectly but why locality is even
approximately true that's why I'm
emphasizing these questions about
momentum and hamiltonians because we
take locality for granted and it's
important in our brains to undo that and
to remember that didn't have to be that
way and to start asking ourselves why it
is that way rather than some other way
ok so I think I got to go you know even
we have we have some of us even in
quarantine we have things we need to do
so there's a few other questions that
were asked that I'm just gonna very very
very quickly and in fact I'm gonna love
them into one big question how do extra
dimensions X DS affect the world we
observe this is a great question because
I said that while they're so small we
can't observe the dimensions directly
but there can be indirect effects it
turns out the answer is in a lot of ways
the parameters of physics so what I mean
by that is the mass of the Higgs boson
the mass of the electron the charge of
the Higgs boson and the electron the
number of dimensions of space obviously
the number of families of particles you
know if you know a little bit about
particle physics
there's something called the electron
and it has a friend of the electron
neutrino
but then it has a heavier cousin the
muon and mule has its own neutrino and
there's another heavier cousin the tau
has its own neutrino so there's three
generations of these particles and in
ordinary particle physics that's just a
fact when you have extra dimensions you
can explain that fact the number of
generations of particles can be tied to
the ways in which the extra dimensions
are curled up and in fact all of these
parameters the masses and charges and so
forth depend on the size and geometry of
the extra dimensions in principle this
is the origin of the landscape of
universes in the string theory
multiverse if you have lots of extra
dimensions you can curl them up in lots
of different ways and the parameters of
physics all look different in those
different ways so even if the extra
dimensions are invisible they are still
very important to us and you know you
can go on to ask well do they have
anything to do with things like dark
matter or dark energy maybe probably not
but it's possible people that absolutely
explored these things again this is the
full employment thing like even when we
don't know the final answers we can have
very very well posed questions when you
have a new idea like extra dimensions it
opens up the space of possibilities it
makes it very very broad so old
questions not even that old but
questions like what is the dark matter
when you say well I might have extra
dimensions could that have anything to
do with dark matter the answer should
always be maybe until you investigate it
very very carefully and that's what we
do right now there is no known direct
relationship between extra dimensions
and dark matter or even dark energy that
there's clearly a potential relationship
between dark energy and extra dimensions
it's too much to go into right now but
it could it could possibly exist because
the dark energy could be one of the
parameters of low energy physics right
the energy density of the vacuum clearly
can depend on the extra dimensions but
we don't have any explanation people
tried I've tried other people have tried
we've written papers but we don't have
any compelling explanation for why extra
dimensions would make the dark matter
or dark energy have exactly the
properties they do so it's still an open
question that's why this is a fun thing
to do even though we're doing the
biggest ideas and pretty basic ideas
like the existence of space it's not
that hard to go from the existence of
space to what are the properties of
space to could these help explain some
of the most pressing mysteries that we
have in physics today